le mans merci de votre réponse monsieur
le directeur général moi je veux
simplement vous remettre le contexte ici
nous sommes dans la commission des
affaires sociales avec des sénatrices et
sénateurs des affaires sociales ça veut
dire que sur leur territoire la commune
le département ils ont exercé des
responsabilités dans le médico social on
va dire pour faire large et dans le
grand âge particulièrement il ay ay si
des personnes qui ont été présidents de
conseils d'administration des pannes
donc nous savons ce qu'est un ehpad son
fonctionnement nous savons les
difficultés et le profit nouveau des
résidents accueillis c'est vrai depuis
quelques années donc voilà ça vous
épargnera peut-être de la pédagogie que
nous avons ici en commun sur ce sujet et
sur la question des repas j'y reviens
est ce que vous confirmez le chiffre de
4 euros 73 73 pour être précis dans la
bouche de monsieur de brink 4 euros 73
hors taxes pour confectionner ce repas
journal mans avec ce délire les quatre
les quatre heureux pas les quatre à cinq
en comptant la collation
madame la sénatrice
excusez moi d'aller voir si j'étais trop
dans la pédagogie je vous présente des
excuses mais ces jeux je les ai vécus
quotidiennement pendant des années
effectivement alors c'est un c'est un
coût alimentaire hors taxes de 4 euros
80 aujourd'hui
encore une fois il faut partir des
besoins et considérer les la négociation
lié à 13 millions de repas servis chaque
année nous avions en 2018
effectuées sur la base de nos menus avec
un constat d'huissier à l'appui
des cours dans des anciennes de grande
distribution et la différence de tarifs
avec des enseignes de grande
distribution était de l'ordre d'un peu
plus d'un euro par rapport à ce que nous
nous pouvons obtenir
même tarif
complété par ce que j'ai sous les yeux
là dans le rapport igas igf le
comparatif entre les les valeurs le
groupement d'étude marché en
restauration collective les gem rcn que
vous connaissez certainement et les
orpea et envoie nettement qu'il ya une
différence de 10 20 voire 30% entre les
recommandations faites au niveau de la
nutrition en général et celle que vous
mettez en place au niveau des repères
c'est pour ça que la question était
posée est ce qu'il ya vraiment une
volonté de réduire drastiquement la
nourriture alors en connaissant tous il
ya beaucoup de médecins ici on pensait
les difficultés d'approvisionnement les
difficultés de de nutrition des
personnes mais voilà ce qu'il y a
vraiment cette volonté de réduire au
maximum le coût journalier de la
nourriture monsieur le sénateur bernard
bonne la réponse est non vous avez vu
que nous avons répondu abondamment
et aux aspects sur la nutrition du
rapport de façon très complète je tiens
un rapport là bien évidemment toutes nos
réponses à vos dispositions la question
est non nous ne ratio non pas
absolument pas aujourd'hui de la moitié
des résidants qui arrive en ehpad sont
dénutris la moitié d'entre eux la moitié
d'entre eux il faut le savoir et et un
an après les deux tiers d'entre eux on
retrouvait un profil bien meilleure il
n'y a pas de rationnement je
n'accepterai jamais de rationné la
nourriture de nos aînés d'un engagement
sous serment est formel que je prends
ici
[Musique]